[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniel holandón ya está con nosotros
en esta mesa de trabajo Daniela
comenzamos una buena Ojalá así sea
semana informativa aquí en directo
América y vamos a hacer un repaso por la
economía de Brasil porque como sabemos
Ayer fue la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales Hola Raúl muy
buenos días una feliz semana también
para usted pues Brasil encara un
crecimiento relativamente robusto
también un desempleo a la baja sin
embargo la alta tasa de pobreza también
la inflación todavía disparada y una
deuda por las nubes son los principales
retos económicos que enfrenta quien sea
que gane la presidencia o viene el
derechista Jair bolsonaro o el líder de
izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien le sacó cinco puntos de ventaja en
la primera vuelta ahora vemos un vistazo
a las principales indicadores este país
tiene una población de 212,6 millones de
los cuales se estima una tercera parte
vive en la pobreza y más del 15% pasa
hambre según estudios
el desempleo ha venido cayendo y hasta
agosto era del 8,9% desde niveles que lo
rondaban el 14% en pleno pico pandémico
la tasa de interés del Banco Central
escaló desde un mínimo histórico del 2%
en marzo de 2021 hasta el 13,75% este
mes Este es su mayor nivel desde 2016 y
está también en línea con lo que están
haciendo el resto de bancos centrales de
la región esto le ha ayudado a la
inflación Aunque sigue siendo altas de
un 8,7% interanual ahora veamos el
crecimiento del pib fue del 4,6% el año
pasado se espera una fuerte
desaceleración para este año al tiempo
que Brasil también acumula una enorme
deuda que es cercana al 80% del pib así
las cosas entonces en Brasil Dani
pasamos a Reino Unido porque el gobierno
de ese país se dio a la presión y
comenzó a ser a deshacer Mejor dicho su
plan económico Así es Raúl bastante
polémico de este plan económico el
ministro de finanzas anunció en marcha
atrás a los planes de reducir la tasa
del impuesto sobre la renta al 40% para
quienes tengan más ingresos esto era
parte de un plan mucho más amplio que
causó bastante controversia y también
pánico en el mercado escuchemos el
anuncio del maestro
simplemente hablamos con la gente
escuchamos a la gente lo entiendo
hablamos con una amplia gama de partes
interesadas y sentimos que el problema
del 45% de impuesto de renta estaba
ahogando un fuerte paquete de
intervención sobre energía un paquete de
intervención sobre recortes de impuestos
para la gente en general y decidimos no
continuar con la eliminación de esa
tarifa de 45%. ahora para conocer más
detalles conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal en Reino Unido Luisa Pulido
Luisa Muy buenas tardes para usted que
llevo Entonces al gobierno a tomar esta
decisión tan drástica y Qué
implicaciones políticas tendría para el
recién llegado gobierno del
Buenas tardes Daniela el anuncio no ha
tranquilizado a los mercados porque el
gobierno británico ha perdido
credibilidad sin embargo las Libra
esterlina poco a poco va recuperando su
valor a media jornada había alcanzado el
nivel más alto en los últimos 10 días y
por supuesto este reversazo tiene un
efecto político no solamente en el
gobierno de listra sino en el futuro de
la primera ministra listas esta semana
completará su primer mes como primera
ministra y ya enfrentar a la primera
rebelión Tori la rebelión de su partido
figuras importantes de la colectividad
han criticado públicamente esta medida
por insostenible por impopular y porque
en esta coyuntura de la crisis del costo
de vida que está azotando a todos en el
país pero especialmente a quienes tienen
menos recursos los conservadores están
reunidos en su asamblea anual en
Birmingham en el centro de Inglaterra y
ese es el tema por supuesto Entonces los
diputados conservadores le han hecho
saber al gobierno que no iban a probar
esta medida en el parlamento por ello el
gobierno
ha reversado esa medida Y eso nos
evidencia Daniela lo débil políticamente
que es el gobierno de listras que apenas
comienza Luisa gracias por toda la
información desde la capital británica
un gran abrazo feliz resto de día y
nosotros Daniela continuamos aquí con
más información económica porque Japón
va a eliminar todas las barreras al
turismo para así recuperar su economía
esto por supuesto tras la pandemia de
Kobe 19 Así es el Primer Ministro fue
mioquicida dijo en un discurso ante el
parlamento que tratará de aprovechar la
debilidad del yen que a propósito Hoy
está en mínimos de 24 años frente al
Dólar esto para fomentar el turismo
entre otras medidas
un gran desafío para la próxima
Primavera es el riesgo de un fuerte
aumento en las facturas de Electricidad
tomaremos medidas Audaces y sin
precedentes que alivien directamente la
carga de los hogares Y las empresas
promoveremos enérgicamente medidas
políticas para maximizar los beneficios
de la debilidad del yen y retribuir al
pueblo japonés a partir del 11 de este
mes reactivaremos el turismo trayendo de
regreso a Los viajeros sin visa para
lograr el objetivo de que gasten más de
35 mil millones de dólares al año Raulín
de dónde surgen todas estas medidas pues
Japón como casi todos los países del
mundo está intentando hacerle frente a
una inflación desenfrenada la diferencia
con este país es que ellos lo que han
hecho es apegarse a la política de tasas
de interés Ultra bajas por parte del
Banco Central como también lo ha hecho
Turquía que ahora veremos un dato de
Turquía Esta es una estrategia muy poco
ortodoxa porque las pautas tradicionales
de la economía ven las tasas de interés
más altas como la mejor manera para des
incentivar el consumo y de esta manera
bajar los precios de la canasta familiar
Dani que nos trae como cifra al día
precisamente hablando de Turquía y a
propósito de su viaje próximo a Turquía
le tengo una mala noticia estoy
emocionado por conocer Turquía Aunque me
tenga malas noticias si no será
emocionar tanto con esta cifra
83,45% esta fue la inflación interanual
en Turquía en septiembre la más alta en
24 años los economistas dicen que este
aumento de los precios se debe
precisamente a esa creencia del
presidente
porque las tasas de interés más altas
conducen a mayores precios totalmente
opuesto a la teoría económica
tradicional que dice que hay que hacer
más caro los préstamos para bajar los
créditos El Banco Central de Turquía
comenzó a recortar las tasas el año
pasado y desde entonces la lira ha
perdido más del 50% de su valor frente
al Dólar esa la buena noticia para mí
Bueno ya le contaré cómo me va entonces
Daniela Muchísimas gracias más adelante
más economía a las 8:45 hora Bogotá
quito Lima Bogotá quito Lima perfecto
salió hoy salimos con todos los deportes
[Música]